but what's weird about Skin Walkers they
were all happening there you know so you
have all these things happening in one
location but as Jim said it's like super
elusive
um it's almost like it'll watch you be
there for a week and then the night
you're driving away to go home it's like
you look in your rear view mirror and
there's something crazy you know and it
almost toys with you that was something
that they all seem to say like it seemed
like it knew that you wanted to see
something you want to do something
whatever what I find fascinating is that
you have this one location where so many
things are happening and it's documented
by a bunch of government people a bunch
of PhD scientists a bunch of people that
have lived there and
um and not only documented over like a
few months we're talking like decades